WITH MORE THAN 3900 DELAYED.
>> Reporter: THE TSA SCREENED
2.44 MILLION PASSENGERS AT U.S.
AIRPORTS ON THURSDAY, JUST SHY
OF A NEW PANDEMIC ERA RECORD.
>> IT FEELS MUCH MORE LIKE 2019
THAN THE PRIOR TWO YEARS.
>> Reporter: 3.5% OF ALL FLIGHTS
THIS YEAR HAVE BEEN CANCELLED.
A 42% INCREASE OVER 2019.
>> THE EARLIER TIME AS POSSIBLE.
AIRLINES POINTED THE AIR TRAFFIC
CONTROL DELAYS CAUSE BY STAFFING
ISSUES AT A KEY FACILITY IN
FLORIDA.
>> WHO IS REALLY TO BLAME WHEN
IT COMES TO THESE MASSIVE
CANCELLATIONS?
>> THE BOTTOM LINE IS THE
AIRLINES SELLING THE TICKETS
NEED TO HAVE THE CREWS AND THE
STAFF TO BACK UP THOSE SALES.
>> Reporter: IN AN E MAIL TO
CUSTOMERS, DELTA AIRLINE IS
APOLOGIZING SAYING THE
ENVIRONMENT WE'RE NAVIGATING IS
UNLIKE ANYTHING WE EVER FACED.
THURSDAY OFF DUTY DELTA PILOTS
ORGANIZED PICKET LINES AT MAJOR
HUBS SAYING THEY ARE OVER
WORKED.
>> WE HAVE BEEN FLYING RECORD
AMOUNT OF OVER TIME TO HELP GET
OUR PASSENGERS SAFELY TO DES
NEIGHS.
>> Reporter: AT THE 24/7 COMMAND
CENTER, THE FAA IS MONITORING
POTENTIAL WEATHER DELAYS IN
CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY FROM
FORECASTED THUNDERSTORM, WIND
AND LOW CLOUDS.
>> NO ONE LIKES TO BE DELAYED
BUT SOMETIMES THAT HAPPENS AND
WE ALWAYS ARE WORKING TOGETHER
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE MITIGATE
THAT AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
>> Reporter: DETA AIRLINE S
ENCOURAGING PASSENGERS TO AVOID
THE MESS.
IT WILL ALLOW ALL PASSENGERS TO
REBOOK THEIR FLIGHT COMPLETELY
FREE OF CHARGE THROUGH JULY 4th.
THERE'S REPORTS THAT PASSENGERS
ON AN OVER BOOKED FLIGHT FROM
GRAND RAPID WERE OFFERED $10,000
TO GIVE UP THEIR SEAT.
THE DELAYS AND CANCELLATIONS ARE
PILING UP.
PAM.
>> WHAT A MESS.
WOW, $10,000.
CAN'T GET OVER THAT.
ARMS SAY THEY ARE CANCELLING
FLIGHTS TO MINIMIZE DISRUPTIONS.
WHY ARE AIRLINES STRUGGLING TO
KEEP UP WITH DEMAND?
>> THE REASON IS THIS.
THE TRAVEL REBOUND HAS BEEN FAR
FASTER AND FAR LARGER THAN I
THINK AIRLINES EXPECTED.
EVEN THOUGH THEY COULD TAKE A
LOOK AT THEIR FUTURE BOOKINGS
FROM THE RESERVATION SYSTEMS.
YOU DON'T JUST WALK IN OFF THE
STREET TO BECOME AN AIRLINE
PILOT AND GO BEHIND THE WHEEL OF
A 737.
THERE WAS A SHORTAGE OF PILOT,
AIR TRAFFIC CONTROLLERS, A LOT
OF DEMAND FOR TRAVEL AND IT JUST
ENDS UP IN THIS CURRENT CHAOS.
SO MANY PEOPLE ARE SAYING WE
WILL FORGET DRIVING AND WE WILL
DRIVE SOMEWHERE.
WE JUST GOT BACK MORE THAN 1700
AIRLINE PASSENGERS SAID THAT 74%
OF THE FOLKS WHO EITHER HAD
FLOWN SO FAR THIS SUMMER OR WERE
PLANNING TO FLY REGRET THEIR
DECISION THE FLY FOR SUMMER
VACATION
.
>> I HAVE A FLIGHT IN A COUPLE O
WEEKS CROSS COUNTRY.
I'M WONDERING SHOULD I TRY TO
MOVE IT TO THE EARLIEST MORNING
FLIGHT TO GO TO MY DESTINATION.
IS THAT SOMETHING PASSENGERS
SHOULD CONSIDER?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
YOU'RE ALWAYS WISEST TO TAKE THE
FIRST FLIGHT OF THE DAY, THE
EARLIEST FLIGHT YOU POSSIBLY CAN
PROVIDED THAT IT MEET YOUR
BUDGET AND YOU CAN TAKE A
NON-STOP, DO SO BECAUSE YOU
REDUCE YOUR RISK OF WHEN YOU
DON'T HAVE TO CONNECT.
ALSO DOUBLE CHECK THE AIRLINE
SCHEDULE.
MAKE SURE IT FLIES EVERY DAY TO
YOUR DESTINATION.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
STORY ABOUT DELTA OFFERING
$10,000 TO PASSENGERS TO LEAVE
AN OVER BOOKED FLIGHT?
WHAT DO YOU THINK THIS SAYS
ABOUT THE THE STATE OF THE
INDUSTRY NOW?
I'VE NEVER HEARD OF THAT HIGH
AFTER A NUMBER.
>> IT'S NOT NEW.
DELTA INITIATED THIS PROGRAM
SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
THEY BASICALLY DO WHAT THEY HAVE
TO DO TO TAKE PEOPLE OFF A PLANE
VOLUNTARILY RATHER THAN TELL
SOMEBODY, SORRY, THERE'S NO SEAT
LEFT FOR YOU
.
UNDER CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES IT'S
WELL WORTH IT.
THE AGENT GOT THE PEOPLE OFF
PLANE WHO HAD THE FLEXIBILITY.
THEY WALKED AWAY WITH $10,000 IN
TRAVEL CREDIT AND MAYBE OTHER
SERVICES.
THE PEOPLE WHO NEEDED TO GET TO
THEIR DESTINATION GOT THERE.
IT'S WIN WIN ALL AROUND.
>> GIVING THE PICKETING WE'RE
SEEING FROM PILOT SAYING THEY
ARE OVER WORKED AND THEIR
SCHEDULES AND PAY, DO YOU THINK
THERE'S FEWER PEOPLE WHO ARE
LOOKING TO BECOME PILOT, TO
ENTER THE INDUSTRY.
IS THAT A CONCERN?
>> THAT'S A REALLY GOOD QUESTION
AND IT HAS BEEN A PROBLEM.
IT CAN TAKE YOU THREE THE FIVE
YEARS TO GET THE EXPERIENCE YOU
NEED TO BECOME AN AIRLINE PILOT.
IT CAN COST 80,000 TO $120,000
TO GET THAT EXPERIENCE.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT THAT VERSUS
OTHER YEARS, YOU'RE PROBABLY
SAYING THE OTHER CAREERS LOOK
BETTER.
UNITED HAS STARTED THEIR OWN
FLIGHT TRAPTRAINING SCHOOLS ANDE
SCHOLARSHIPS AVAILABLE.
THE STARTING PAY IS A LOT